hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar role of
chromosomal microarray
in the era of genome sequencing i'm
alexis krauss of labberts
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labbert
and brought to you by agilent to learn
more about our sponsor
please visit their website at
agilent.com
encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i would like to now welcome our speaker
dr richard choi
professor department of obstetrics and
gynecology
deputy director of prenatal genetic
diagnosis center
and director of the pre-imp implantation
genetic diagnosis laboratory at the
chinese university of hong kong
dr choi will be presenting data obtained
using a custom
cgh plus snip array named fetal chip
for more information about our presenter
please visit the biography tab
at the top right of your screen dr choi
welcome sir you may now begin your
presentation
um thank you alex for the introductions
first of all i would like to
thank agilent's invitations so today for
the next 45 minutes
i'm going to share with you uh in three
aspects
first of all all i would like to
introduce about our chinese university
of hong kong
and then i'm going to share our
experience why there's a need for us to
design
this video chip regarding the principle
of
cma as well as advantage and limitations
and the last part of my talk i'm going
to share with you
some of our vicious funding regarding
how we can make use of the chromosomal
microarray
and also what's the benefits regarding
the need
to detect aoh as well as uvd using
the a raid okay
so um welcome to our beautiful campus
this is our chinese university campus
uh in hong kong uh we our our campus
actually can
have many unique features right and i
extend our most warm welcome to you when
you have time to
come to hong kong chinese university
hong kong is ranked
30th in asia and also
within the top 50 university under the
qs score
and you can see from the red dot here
actually hong kong is
quite a tiny place but you can see that
we are
located within the great bay areas
in in in asia so that's why we were able
to get connected
to a lot of our other places in the
world
regarding our department the department
of optics and gynecology we are the
largest public
omg unit in hong kong we are serving
about 1.7 million people
live in hong kong and we oversee over
7000 birth annually we are specialized
not just in assisted reproductive
medicine we also have a
uk royal college accredited a fellow
training center
in physical maternal medicine uh you
know gynecology as well as
other specialties and for the lab that
i'm
working and take care actually we are
divided into four uh specialties we have
our endology lab
which uh mainly you know are looking
into the
test for male infertility we have our
pre-implantation genetic screening and
testing facility
which in conjugation with our prenatal
genetic diagnosis lab
in both molecular and keral typing as
well as the con
conventional biochemical screening lab
for the dance building
we are collaborating and serving both
the build
active medicines as well as the federal
medicine unit
in hong kong as well as in the region
so we provide both a service under our
public hospital system as well as
receiving
samples from private hospitals including
international samples
from thailand malaysia and singapore
just let us share with you a little bit
about the history of our development
uh everything we start from the first
trimester start swinging
in our university as early as in uh 2003
and subsequently these downscreening
programs were funded
under the hospital authorities so it
means that all the public patients in
hong kong they were able to receive this
as a field child surface
and because of the screening actually we
we understand there's need
to develop the cytogenetics as well as a
molecular genetic test like the gel
typing
and qlpcl to provide a rapid and
accurate diagnostic test so all this
happens
in 206 and because of the
you know the introductions about the
cochlear variant we start to look into
the applications of the chromosomal
molecular rate
in the 2004 and subsequently we start to
decide
our customer array and implement it in
the surface in 2009
with the cgx steep and indeed we also
study and explore its applications in
pre-implantation genetic testing for
antibody as well
so with this array of tests uh you can
see this is
um our hospital campus where we are
and we also have developed another ring
of the research unit in china so that we
are able to cater the need
both in hong kong as well as those uh
from china as well okay so
um with this development the other very
important landmark we have done is we
collaborate with baylor college of
medicine
where we start to offer short course and
training course in kindergenetics in
asia pacific regions
to receive delegates in this vision
because we know there's a very important
for us
to learn how to interpret and generate
those
performance copy the more variants we
identified as well as
you know those of uh single nuclear
variants nowadays we can
appreciate by both the exon sequencing
or by the genome sequencing
so um that's all about our chinese unit
of hong kong so to move on
why we need to do um uh to have a
customer device video chips
and how the cma is important on prenatal
diagnosis
actually in fact all this began in the
year of 2004
where professor charles lee and the
other group they published
you know two papers in
science and nature genetics to
appreciate that actually between our
genome there are dna segment
which is present in a variable copy
number like what i showed you in the
chromosomes
where you see the yellow region is a
region where you could get
duplicated in our in our genome and from
that time we start to appreciate that
indeed our genome is not as simple as
what we know in the old days right our
two presidents from america that we only
have
slip difference that's contributed to
about 0.1 percent
in fact this difference within our
individuals they are not just because of
the sleep
there are many many uh small segments of
cochlear movarian changes
like what i show you in this figure
right no matter we are talking about
chromosome 1
or to chromosome to the sex chromosome
there are a lot
of small segments of the changes and
this changes even in the old days we
know that it could be more than
500 million base pair and you can see
that what i capture in the box is the
data
from the dgb which is the database of
genomic variants i'm sure most of you
that were in genetically familiar with
that
you can see that the data in
1 2 2012 is only a total entry
of about 100 000 and you can see that up
to last year
right you can see that the number of
cmes is almost you know
increase in fifo it's mainly because we
are able to see there are more
high resolution data as well as there
are more
samples input from the others so you can
see that
with this discovery of copy number
variants
we now start to appreciate that actually
the scale of our genome variant is not
as simple as in the old days
we're talking about single nuclear
variant like you know the lunar syndrome
that's due to the mutation in the rest
of pre-pathway that may be a field
database
a field base pair or by indel
to extend that actually there are coffee
number variant changes they could be
as small as only talking about 50 base
pair to expect
as you know tens of millions of base
pair
and one of the most uh representative
one is the 22q one one point two
which is a jaw syndrome it could be a
three megabase or a one point
five megabase uh deletions and
that have not including those of you
know um
other complex commercial movie
arrangements that we can appreciate
uh by uh scale typing or we can also
detect a bar ray if there's a perfect
deletion or duplication and in the old
days in our prenatal or in
even in the pediatric you may be talking
about genetic disorder related with
birth defect we always only
reference to you particularly you know
um como
some numerical changes tesla and the
probability the most representative is
down syndrome
you can see that from this diagram now
we have a
big array of difference of disease that
we need to take care
and because of this need when we
characterize them into the
type of methods that we can detect we
can see that
we have been practiced since in the
1970s that
any commercial disorder we can use
our as our skillful cytogeneticists do
cell culture and then we can identify
as tiny as what i show you in the red
circuits that there are three copies
of the chromosome 21 that's representing
one of the most common choice for me
but now that's not enough because we
know that there's a new group of
copy number variant disorder they could
be like what i highlight in the box it
could be
a deletion of a small region or it could
be a duplication
of a small region like this duplication
of the
the blue c square and this we need
a different method which is the
microarray
or in the old days we know that all the
mendelian disorder they are mainly
because of monogenic disorder that we
can
characterize by uh sanger sequencing so
we've done
actually what we now look for is that
can we have a technology
that at least can take care of both the
common thermal disorder that i saw here
as well as the pathogenic cochlear
movarian that have been
you know highly appreciated in the last
15 years with the discovery of
new medical deletion and micro
multiplication syndrome
so instantly what we can think or what
we can learn
from our lab or from our test book is
that there's a method
called chromosomal microarray analysis
in short we call in cma nowadays so cma
actually it could be divided into two
um two uh uh platforms or method one is
array subject which is a comparative
generic hybridization mainly looking
into
region of general losses or the second
one is a single nucleotide polymorphism
sim arrays
that are developed by a different
company
but in general actually they share a
very similar principle so i'm going to
walk
through the principle for some of you
that are not familiar with
this technology so uh generally when
we're talking about a microarray
we are referring to that we are picking
you know clones or segments of sequence
our genome
and then we immobilize them right this
clones
into a solid phase usually it's a glass
line
so after we immobilize into the glass
line
we labeled a con a genomic
uh dna that we're going to test in one
fluorescent color
uh here i give you an example as a green
fluorescence and then we also
have the same amount of dna from a
reference
normal healthy control genome that we
labels with a red fluorescent color
so what we do is very simple once they
are labeled
they are hybridized to the same cloned
in the array because if the amount of a
sequence
is the same and they are specific they
were going to hyperlyze and give a very
unique
fluorescent signal and by looking into
these signals
actually we were able to detect the
result okay so to reflect this in a more
uh simple cartoon okay so the test
samples
we label as a regular and then we have
the control sample
they are labeled with a green color in
theory if both of the genome they carry
the same
genomic content they be the same so
we'll have equal amounts of voices
signal but
if our test samples have a gain of a
phasor chromosome or a particular region
after we do the hybridization then we
have a gains of the red color
so that's how we see there are more red
signals okay so to refract that
on the microarray this is what the
microarray scans
okay so when we zoom in each of the
of the clones you can see that by
reading out this fluorescent signal
because we know exactly
where these probes are so by reading the
signal we are able
can you know have them aligned back to
our genome
okay so if there's no signal gain or
loss like what we pretend
represents here as a zero lie so you can
see that is a balance
but we have a gains of the signal from
our patient
like in this case is a red fluorescence
color so you can see that we see
you know many red dots they go to the
plus one so we know that there's a gain
of copy
but also contradict in the other way if
there's a loss of our patient signal
then that means
the control referencing will increase so
that's why we can see
this increase in green fluorescence so
it represents a loss of the signal from
the patient
so by doing that we were able to see
and know exactly where there is a
genomic
copy number changes in our genome so
with that actually is very robust
we can use different chromosomal
microarray
platform like the asylum the illumina or
the alpha matrix
but now there's only um the agilent
and alpha matrix platform they also have
both oligo and the snip array
so i'm going to tell you why they are
better later but i think for you the
most important thing is like
this table i show you right in the
market there are many different
microarray platforms
and most of time they will tell you how
many you know a rate
how many markers they will have it but
what we need to bear in mind is more
important
to look at what i show you in the modes
right is the plug per snip matter or per
marker that means
if they only sample in the same place
many times they still only have the same
you know resolution that does not
enhance the resolution but the more the
number of the probes they have okay
so that is very important information we
need to know the resolutions of the
array
then we know how good they were able to
detect what's the smallest size of the
copy the more variance they can do
i'm going to explain this a little bit
more later okay
so to make it simple the most key
important key message for microarray or
cma is that it's
equal to a high resolution tail typing
what it means
right it means that nowadays we know
that the best resolution for kl typing
we are usually referred to a resolution
of
5 million base pair or more that means
geotapping cannot
detect any deletion or duplication
that they are smaller than 5 million
base pair so just like
here we have a picture we show the pixel
we know that this is a
human individual but it's hard to tell
you know who
is he or she it's because of the lack of
the
resolutions but by microarray because we
have enhanced the resolutions
from 5 million base pair to 100
kilobase pair so that is a 50 times
enhancement
in resolution so with that what we can
see is that we are able to see
clearly where the sequence were apparent
okay just like a picture we can have a
very clear resolution
and we know that oh this is a gentleman
and in fact
he's the chairman of our our department
professor tiwala so that is what we mean
how a cma have a better resolution than
caltech
okay so what i'm going to share with you
is
okay we what we know about this
technology okay why we need this
in genetic diagnosis particularly in
prenatal diagnosis and why we need to
move
from a catalar array to a customized
rate
that we use in clinical okay
so first of all we all understand that
when we're talking about prenatal
diagnosis
in the old day everything starts from
down swimming okay
so we talk about you know we need to
screen for common tries on me
like trisomy 21 18 and 13
okay because they are the most prevalent
and chashumi 13 and 18
they are even you know not compatible
with fly but now
we all know that this has been
this has been take care well by the
non-invasive pineal testing
because it gives a very good sensitivity
and specificity
particularly for tries only 71 but
in fact when we're talking about
prenatal diagnosis for high risk
pregnancy
we are talking about features with
different type of ultrasound
modalities it could be as common as
high level translucency like highlight
here in the fetus
that you can see you know an access
during the first trimester
or they are simply just by high risk by
down syndrome uh
base theorem screening or it could be
more complicated that
they we see this in the second trimester
morphology scan like this case with a
cufflink and pilot
okay and we were able to get
a very precious sample i
by amiocentesis by cvs or even by condos
and thesis
so with that there's a need that we need
to diagnosis
a lot of different type of disorder not
just
talking about uh common numerical
disorder that's why
medical array were able to help to pick
up the pathogenic copy of more variant
the second reason for needs for
microarray is that it's not
uncommon that we can receive a
cytogenetic report where it shows you
that this chromosome 7
where the right hand side one is shorter
than the half left hand side
right and we are suspect there may be
laws
of some of the genetic content of this
region
right so we want to know where is this
exact relation
and also does it affect other
chromosomes and if we know the gene
content
of this region we were also able to
help the clinical genetic and the
genetic counseling regarding what is the
chemical significance of this
so with all this this drive the needs of
how
we can use the commercial microarray
okay
so um we we learned all this uh in the
early days in the 2004 and six because
that is really the blooming
of the copyright and microarray so we
feel very excited uh from that time okay
so from that what we have in the market
is like what you can see now right we
can have
iphone 12 iphone 5 iphone 6.
the difference what we know is of course
the resolution right
so if we take the actual microarray as a
sample we can have the one million
high density agilent array we can also
have
the low density 60k
microarray but if we are only on 60k
it's called eight times 60k is because
prior rate we can do
examples so for the clinical need what
is our trade-off right we can go
for a ferrari that's one million or we
can go to a more reasonable local car
or japanese car that serve the same
purpose
but it's much cheaper on the road right
and we know that the main difference
is that the higher the density the oligo
or the steep float the better the
resolution
so with that in mind okay it's also
the time where the american congress of
prostrate and gynecologists in
209 they start to issue their community
opinion
regarding the use of microarray they say
that conventional chaotic
remains the principal solid genetic
tools in prenatal diagnosis
an array suggests in contact with the
genetic counseling can be offered
as an adjunct tools in prenatal case
with abnormal anatomical funding so that
means
even within our professional community
we can appreciate that
this new technology has this advantage
that is useful right but it's not
replacing the first-year conventional
cytogenetic kale typing and why is that
what is the issue
okay so i'm sharing with you the this is
really the first case we do at that time
you can see that at that time even
azurin the best fresh solution
is a 244k array okay
and in fact this is a typical first
trimester case of trisomy 21 right you
can see that a highlight
in the blue box you can see in the
chromosome 21 there's
increase of signal where you can see is
highlighted by
the red bar but at the same time
actually you can see that across the
genome
from chromosome 1 all the way to
chromosome 22
we also detect and see there are regions
of in the left
represent copy number loss or to the
right
which represent a copy number gained
okay
so for researcher it will be very
excited because you can see there's a
lot of copy number variant
and you want to know what they are but
if you are a clinician
you just want to make a diagnosis you
will become very worried
because in a conventional way by the kel
typing this is just a typical
transformational one down syndrome baby
it's very easy to counsel
but now you can see there's a lot of
other region in our genome
that they are deleted or duplicated so
what's the clinical significance
how should we tell the parent
right regarding this pregnancy or even
for pediatric cases with down syndrome
okay so this raised a lot of issue
particularly
two concerns okay the clinicians
they are very concerned about the
genotype phenotype correlation
and the for the laboratory director
because you are going to write the
report
to ease the report to the clinician and
the patient we all worry about the
detections
of cochlear variants of unknown
significance okay
and this is not just on one array design
okay you can see this is another this is
the east coast
array and that time that's one of the
most popular use clinically
you can see that actually this is on a
cap
you know quality qap result you can see
that
in this sample although we can detect
there are deletion and duplication on
chromosome 8
but again there are many variants of
unknown solution there's a total of 21.
so it makes the interpretations uh very
difficult
for routine diagnostic lab so with all
these issues what we think is that wow
can we actually remove this known you
know population based benign copy the
movarians
and also some you know uncertain
certified visions
okay just like uh you can see here okay
each job represent
one probe sequence in our genome and you
can see that
those in green is this is a region that
have been known and curated by many
groups
like so on the x g18 cmv track there
it's a common copy number variant but
it's not clinical significant so what we
do is
at the middle one we try to put in less
product in this region and give
a more even space so that when we do it
next time because
by array you need to have a consecutive
three or more than free product to call
a copy limit change
so by that you can see that now this
region becomes
not detectable and it is you know it's
normal so this is
what we mean by remove the benign copy
number and or those with
uncertain chemical significance and you
can see that once we remove that
actually we can save a lot of props
for other regions okay so what we do
with
with the other region is that we try to
maintain a high resolution across the
genome
approximately 100 kb but then we try to
you know take out
those of the nine copy the bavarian so
with that you can see that
when we compare our result again with
the e square array that is the one in
the
uh orange color with two cursor
that's the left one that's our design
you can see that we have the same
capacity
of detecting the pathogenic one but we
do not see
two common capillary variants in this
chromosome 14
okay so this is one approach the second
approach is that
we know that all technology has its
limitations same as a microarray
you can see that although this is a
typical example of trisomy 21 you can
see that all the same
signal they go to the plus one but if
you look carefully for those that are
circle
right they are they are not respond they
do not generate a very good
hybridization signal
to give you a choice only 21. so what we
do we also take this
probe up okay so that means we have
quite a good and significant you know
uh more than a few thousands of probes
that we can use
to to enhance so what we do with that
actually we use them
right to enhance those we know
well-defined
pathogenic region so for example like
this one right the left hand side is the
asylum
244k category array you can see that
for the prelimbili and angelman syndrome
region for this ube
3a they are not highly densely
populated so what we did we enhanced the
plot in this region so that we were able
to ensure that we give a
better detection of the vision okay so
after we finished uh this modification
this is an example uh to show how good
is this customer design you can see that
this is a well-known vision uh related
with
chocolate tube type 1a disease it's on
the
bmp 22 genes 22 genes that show here
the blue box is the array
from the catalog from azure and you can
see that each of the lines represent the
probe here so you can see that
from the top the two 1 million
density array they give a very good
distribution
detection division but if you go down to
the 2 times 400
k and 4 times 180 k you can see that the
plug density in this dc
region is very poor and for the steep
array actually they are doing pretty
well but you can see that
they are not evenly distributed it's
mainly because they are
based on the presence of the sleep in
the region but
for our feeder chips although it's only
60k but you can see that each of the
black
color bar here you can see that we give
a much more even distribution
and enhance uh the probe in this disease
region
so this is the principle how we our
feeder tubes
okay so with this design we also
implement
with the steep array okay across the
whole genome of the chromosome
so that we understand that that will
enhance us to detect what
parents also doesn't mean others so that
is the
what we call fetal dna troops in hong
kong and in asia that we have been using
so how we appreciate that
the microarray is a very good approach
in prenatal diagnosis i want to share
with you
this one of our earlier cases that we
understand the beauty of customer array
design
and how that can help in a patient okay
so this is a very typical case that you
may encounter in your
daily practice right this is a referral
from a perfect
doctor with suspected cystic hydroma and
that gestational week 13
our ultrasound revealed that it's a high
level translucency
and 9.1 mm with the edema of the
fetal scalp so because it's the first
trimester so we quickly
you know a consensus patient and then we
do cvs
we send for qr pcr and calc typing and
within a day the qrp sales result come
back and it revealed that it's
not we have excuse for common
transforming because high nt
could be you know uh highly associated
with common transforming
and it also revealed that actually this
is a male fetus
but when we follow up on a morphology
scan
at week 13 we can see that
it is ambiguous genitalia we can see
that on the left
is where you can see the fetus janitor
where uh you know you can see the right
cursor you can see that this is a tulip
side
right like the flower tulip so it
actually this is more represent a female
genital
okay but our qfp pcr result is male
so actually there's a discordance of
results so this could be
a lab error or it could be this we just
have a
hypo status but at the meantime you can
see that the
liquid flow is persistently high okay so
with that
okay we wait for another week because
the gold standard is great for kale
typing and you can see that
gel typing we sell come back it's quite
a pretty
standard and good resolution chaotic and
you can see that it confirmed our result
this is a fetus a male fetus
but morphology scan was a
uh you know ambiguous genitalia okay
so with that we encounter a very
uh uh important issue okay normal qf
and normal kl type result it cannot
explain the
increased glucose translucency as well
as the ambiguous genitalia
but now we have the microarray okay so
what we do
we take the cvs and uh you know compare
with the normal dna
and then we use our desired uh
philosophy
to do the analysis okay so within a week
what we see is that you can see that
okay this is the
the middle is the co line each of the
clause means the plot you can see that
there
is a enhanced cluster of plot
showing a loss of one copy of signal
which
is located in the cp2 gene this is only
about 200 plus kilobase pair it's too
small
so that explains why it was not able to
be picked up
by kel typing but at the meantime
actually this is the
first case in prenatal csct2
it never been detected so we look into
literature we know that for cpt2
actually it is known to be reported with
more wilson syndrome okay and on more
vision syndrome we know that they have
some typical features right uplift year
look
triangular shape uh hyperterrorism
okay and of course there are some you
know ultrasound ammunitive
congenital heart or androgenesis of
copper colossal
so with all these clinical findings we
were very confident with our array
and we informed the patient and then
patient uh
go for termination pregnancy and you can
see that we can see triangular gene
obliteral
angiogenesis of cocolosa and hypospadia
and this confirmed as the first case of
molar syndrome and
in fact it's not that rare because in
old days they only
diagnosed in the pre in in in the
pediatric case because there's a lot of
tools to to do that so you can see that
our first paper is copies in 20110
in green journal but subsequently in
2014 we also
prepared another one because it's almost
like every year we do see a case of a
mobile user syndrome
by the microarray so that explains how a
good customer design microarray is
important
to enhance for the disease detections
okay so this
echoes all our you know world leaders in
this field like uh twice abu dhabi
and david laver and mr schaffer that
you know no matter in prenatal or
postnatal testing
microarray are taking over the field of
cytogenetic
for studying chromosomal immunities
particularly related with
copy number variant this technology has
proven to be useful
in several clinical settings including
in both postnatal diagnosis
and now we can see there are great
potential in prenatal dinosaurs
that was exactly what we see at that
time
okay and you can see that uh a few of
the landmark application for example
this is the one in american journal of
human genetics
where it showed that right in the
pediatric cohort you give a higher
diagnostic yield
okay from 15 to 20 percent for
unexplained developmental delay
intellectual disability
and autism than keral typing okay and
in the prenatal cohort it also depends
on you know the indications
of or the entertainment of your cohort
it range from
one to five percent or even higher if
you have
those with more of ultrasound modalities
okay
so with that actually it bring up a very
important point it's because
okay this is a work that we collaborate
with uh dr
francesca gratty okay you can see that
for common transforming okay they are
related with advanced maternal aids but
you can see that for micro deletion
syndrome particularly for the 21 um
to the george as well as the probability
and androgen
actually it is not related with the age
so that means any woman if they go
for a prenatal diagnosis right the only
way
you want to detect for this micro
deletion and micro deficition is you
have to go for microarray because scale
typing will not able
to detect them okay so with that
actually it brings up okay who should be
used what should be used for
daily clinical practice so to share our
our experience in
chinese junior hong kong we think that
one of the most common
scenarios you may encounter and use is
like what i show you in the example
it's not uncommon you see a high anti
cases but no
chaotic so this group of patients they
will be very best to use because the
woman will always ask
how abnormal is my baby is there
anything we can take care
of course a cochlear mobilian is not the
only one
they could also due to you know a lunar
syndrome restorative profit
but you can see that based on our
publication and others for any features
with high nt if there are
also other outside minority you are able
to have a very good diagnostic you up to
20
if they only have nt uh uh
alone right uh now we use a cut off of
3.5 but the first study was only
at three at three millimeter still you
can have about a one to
five percent of um diagnostic yield okay
so uh in order
um to have a better idea whether you
know what is the diagnostic you on
different
you know indication like you know the
cufflink and pallet we can see that it
can go up to about
14 uh my students uh try to
do a summary of our result as well as a
meta analysis
so what we do is that we look at the
characteristics of this pathogenic
popular variant
we get all the published data using
microarray in the literature
from those from the high risk group as
well as those
reported in the low risk group in a
total we got about
23 000 cases so what we can see is that
actually pathogenic
copyright were underappreciated in low
risk pregnancy what i mean
we know that for high risk pregnancy
where we refer to is abnormal ultrasound
funding
or they have a high risk by you know a
down screening
it's about 1 in 36 that means
1 in 36 pregnant women they already
undergo an invasive procedure if you go
test for microarray
they will have a positive pathogenic
copyright result
and here we're only talking about those
topogenic copper number
variant they are less than 10 megabits
how about for the low risk
right low risk we refer to that only
because of advanced methodology
or because of maternal anxiety you can
see that steel is very high it's
one in 125 and that is exactly echo
the the curve i just show you the
collaboration that we work with uh
dr francesca granty that even for the
low
risk case because of the medical
deletion
syndrome they are not age dependent only
microarray were able to help you to
detect that
and if we look into more detail actually
you can see that
within these 419 pathogenic copy number
variant
most of them you can see that 84 of them
actually they are less than
five billion base pair so you
can say we're sure they will be missed
by kl typing
okay and we will look into more details
by the indication you can see that
right the highest diagnostic yield is
still those with
abnormal ultrasounds and those only with
advanced maternal age is low but still
is significant okay and overall you can
see that anyone
if they already go under a invasive
procedure the diagnostic yield of
pathogenic cochlear malware
less than 10 megabytes by microarray is
1.6
so it actually is this echo what uh
wrong retina they put they published in
new england journal of medicine
that microarrays should be recommended
as a first tier test
okay so that's why you know we need to
choose a good resolution array because
by looking in this pathogenic copied
movement you can see that most of them
only have a medium size of around
0.47 million base pair okay
so you need a good resolution so you can
detect
all of them of course every technology
has its limitation
so uh in our case we all understand that
for microarray because
we are using probes and probe could be
unevenly distributed
like the net here all right some of the
have a more
wider spacing some may have a last one
so this is one of the
limitation of microarray but as far as
we understand that
we can still make full use of that okay
so uh for this part okay again i want to
highlight is that different manufacturer
different category array can have a
different resolution like this is
another region
this is a sip two for ends sentence
carefully
okay you can see that okay some of the
array
particularly those on the slip array
they have no proper it's totally empty
okay so you may miss it because there's
no probe okay
but for uh for those customers
like those from us the fetal dna chip or
the from
from baylor we have been enhanced the
the coverage of the property that's why
you're able to give a better result so
with that
that's why now actually right
all the data from us from the community
and from different publication has
support
cmas should be used as a first tier test
in the
in the earlier days only talking about
ultrasound monot
but now you can see that actually it's
recommended for any woman
who undergo uh invasive procedure right
and they have an advantage also on the
turnaround time center in our center is
seven days compared to cal typing
that's two weeks yeah so with all this
uh support
actually in hong kong locally uh since
uh
june 2015 this is also become
a publicly available free service for
all the women's in hong kong
and for urgent case actually we were
able to achieve
a turnaround time of two days
particularly for those patients they're
already in week
22 or 23 that you need to make a
decision before big 24
so we are able to achieve in a clinical
diagnostic way but with another
accreditation
and also with a very good turnaround
time okay
so this is all about the sharing about
how microarrays were useful so in the
last
10 minutes i'm going to share with you a
study
that to show how important to counsel a
high risk pregnancy patient
whether they should use a non-invasive
approach or use microarray for the
application
and also a few slides you know to recap
about the importance of aoh
all right so as as like my topic
my title have has mentioned right we are
now in the
era of genome sequencing we know that
there's a lot of new technology
like you know high def whole genome
sequencing
or the low pass whole genome sequencing
ladder one developed in a lab we know
that
by using uh low profit genome sequencing
we are able to have a better throughput
than our rate uh for confidential
variant analysis
but again for the low pass sequencing
technology
they still need a longer turnaround time
array
which were able to give you a two you
know within a two days
that is still you know clinically very
important particularly for
prenatal diagnosis so with that in mind
okay i'm going to
share with you a very common question
that have been asked by a patient is
that
right if it's already a high risk
pregnancy maybe because of advanced
mother age
or you know other
risk calculations it's common for them
to ask
should they go for the nipt or they
should go for the microarray
the disadvantage of microarray is
because they are afraid of the
miscarriage risk
of the extra of 1.2 percent
but now we all know that all right uh
it's not
uh uh that much of this miscarriage risk
okay so what we asked the question is
that if we have a high risk uh pregnancy
okay we have them in parallel
tests for both nips and cma
okay so for the cma we use our feeder
chips
and then for nips we use genome y
nipt at three million base pair
resolution this is a
study by my phd student uh mr here
okay so what we group as harvest here is
including a patient with
advanced material age alone patients
with fetal structure immorality
or they have positive family history
okay so and you can see that
okay in total there are 744
patients and for the nipt there are
550 uh patients have a positive result
that has already excluded the sex
communism abnormality and the cma
there's only 32.7 percent of them
have the result so why there's a
difference first
let's look at the common choice for me
we can see that for the common choice
for me
for the red square i highlight you can
see that there's a significant
discrepancy
the result no matter we're talking about
trisomy 21
or trust me 13. one of the reasons is
because of the false positive result but
the more
important is because of the resolution
difference so let's look at
the the numerical uh funding first okay
so you can see from here okay for all
the positive uh nips we sell related
with rare anti-party that means not
including
uh chromosome 21 they are all
represented by the buba
you can see that from question 2 to
chromosome 22
we do have more common positive funding
in common 7 and 8 and 15
but how much of them were able to have a
positive diagnosis result they are only
represented by the orange bar
so you can see that it's very little so
that brings up the fact that there's a
lot of false positive results
by nipt compared to a diagnostic test by
the microarray
second if we look at the size of the
pathogenic copper variant
detected uh by nips and cma you can see
that
nips and cmv results were only core
coordinates in 33 percent of the cases
right here we don't need to mention
about the loh and uvd because this is a
unique thing
cma can detect that nips cannot detect
but even for the largest one
larger than five megabase or smaller
than
um five megabytes there's still a high
this call
this this concordance okay so let's take
um
some of them as example okay so within
the
um these 9.8 cases of discordance
results
right we can see that some of the
discordance right
is not just confined to those
it's larger than five megabytes we
actually see more that they are less
than
five megabits as if you focus on the
third columns of the table
so what are they okay you can see that
one of the main reasons to explain this
discordance
is that okay when we um do that
the cma right uh this public genetic
funding
uh apologize if it's two small uh font
size for you
you can see that most of them they are
small professionally copy them awareness
right
it's small as 1.6 megabytes and 3.5
megabits so this is one of the typical
reasons
why nipd missed it because of
sensitivity of these sequencing
platforms
were not able to go down to that high
resolution okay
and the the rare another very important
point i want to raise up is that
there were pathogenic coping ovarian
detected among
nips negative case is as high as one in
17
among these high risk groups so that
demonstrates the beauty of microarray
why is because some of them are uvd
or tripod that can only detected by
their rate so this is
why they missed it you can see it's
about one point four percent
other is that some of the chromosomal
immunity are mr and ips they are
detected by microarray that may be
because of
the limited sensitivity and specificity
of the platform
and also if you only consider
prophecying copyright
additional genetic aberration detected
by cma
is one in 17 among high-risk pregnancy
who were given a negative or
non-reportable
ni psv cell so with that actually what
it shows is that right when we compare
the application of nipt versus
microarray
in prenatal diagnosis among high risk
women
actually although nipt can have a high
positive rate
but in fact most of them are false
positive
if we only talking about trachoma21
they're good because we don't miss
anything but
cma able to allow detection of small
pathogenic
cochlear variants and they're very
important for prenatal diagnosis
right just like what i demonstrate here
so for those of you are important in
this world you're most welcome to look
into the paper from
from yog okay yeah so this is about all
for profit generally copyright and as i
mentioned why we also need to have the
snip
in our in our chips besides because we
know that
you need parental diatom is important
because you need parental dyson
upd means inheritance of both
homologous of a chromosome pair from
only one parent
or no copy from the second parent in a
deeper genome
okay so it could be a maternal or
paternal origin
and you can see that based on this
largest dataset from
dr thomas from germany right you can see
that there are more than
3600 upd cases has been reported
and if you look at another publication
in the american journal of human
genetics where they look into close to
a million parents student pair you can
see that
upd is not just confined to one
chromosome it can
go all across all the chromosomes right
and it could be both
paternal and maternal origin right so by
identifying this
information is very important
particularly if there's a possibility of
an autosomal recessive
condition right so to adjust that
actually our customer array
we are also uh including a
enzyme digestion step so that we are
able to enhance the detections
of the sleep as well and by optimization
actually we are able to reduce the
volume and then
actually the whole process the protocol
for the testing is
you know a 30 reduction compared to the
total cost and this uniqueness and the
importance
of sleep for the detentions of
pathological
upd or aox is not just by us you can see
that there are
other paper published by the australian
group as well as
from the chinese group that is important
to detect this
uh pathogenic in significant copyright
variants
and in asia the other important thing is
that we have a lot of consequential
marriage okay so
with this uh snipped uh information
actually we are also able to understand
you know the architect of the family and
also look into the conceptuality of the
prenatal samples
okay so uh to summarize my talk
okay um this uh physical chip is array6
for snip array it's eight times 60k
with a average of 100 kilobase genome
wide resolution in the backbone
you have an enhanced probe coverage in
disease region
okay you have a high sensitivity and
selectivity
in diagnostic yield both in the prenatal
and postpartum cohort
as uh you know uh uh you know
demonstrated in
our publications okay you are able to
have a high throughput that you can do
examples for chips
and it is very robust with a very low
experimental
failure rate and as i mentioned in
prenatal is particularly important
because you have a fastest turnaround
time
it's within two days right so far um
up to last year we have uh uh you know i
conducted more than fifteen thousand
uh trips okay this including
collaborations in asia
as well as in europe and uh and uk
okay so all this as a conclusion from my
talk is that
actually microarray as the acmg standard
guidelines
have been recommended this microarray
analysis
is recommended and should be included in
both the postnatal
and prenatal application and
this is my email and thank you for
listening and i
am open for questions and the prospect
the money to alisa thank you
thank you dr choi for that informative
presentation
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
i would also like to introduce valentina
mariam the global product manager for
microarrays at agilent to join us for
this q a session
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we're going to
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started dr choi our first
question is
what is an average probe spacing in the
target sites
oh thank you for the question so uh our
medium proof spacing
for the overall genome is 22 kilobase
pair and you know target region is 5 kb
so that's why like the first case i
illustrate we have an
enhanced pop intensity and how that we
were able to detect
this kind of small micro deletion
syndrome that were missed by
other microarray platforms
great thank you so much for that um
moving on to
our next question from the audience are
telomeric regions covered
oh yes because the uh parametric region
is very important so it's well covered
the mean probe spacing is actually at 2
kb
is highly dense
thank you so much um let's see
oh here's a good one for you so dr choi
do you see
do you see as a risk the massive use of
nipt
providing a false sense of security if
not linked to appropriate genetic
counseling
uh thank you this is a very
important question like i showed in my
last study by my phd student you can see
that by using
ni pt for genome y resolution there's a
lot of
false positive results so that brings
the importance that actually for this
kind of high risk
patients actually using microarray as a
diagnostic test will be much more
accurate and appropriate
than the nipt
this audience member number one wants to
compliment you and say very good talk
and their question is in your opinion
when could wgs replace cma
oh thank you uh i think um it's not
really uh replaced
why i say that is because when we're
talking about wgs which stand for whole
genome sequencing
we are talking about a very uh
high red depth uh technology okay
so in theory with that technology we can
take care of both
single nucleotide point mutations that
currently take care by
west and we can also uh you know look
into
uh copy the bavarian they were able to
pick up by
cma or even you know balance
translocation and structural variant
that have been developed
in our lab okay so you can see that
actually these two
technologies they are taking care of
different arrays of
disease okay but uh back if we take the
example of in the prenatal right
it's difficult for each of the case
coming and then you do the whole genome
sequencing it's
first of all it's too expensive second
there's a
too many data and there's so many
variants of unknown solution
in both copylabarian and single
nucleotide variant
okay so with that right if the the
the primary goal is to make a prenatal
diagnosis of non-micro deletion micro
duplication
and chromosomal immunity then there's no
way
wgs can take over cma because cma is
cheaper
more robust and more to a confined
detection list
okay but in terms of research of course
there's always a position
for wgs to have all these so i think
within a very short you know period
within two or three years
or even up to five years is not
ready for the wgs to take over cma yet
in the respect of the confined detection
needs as well as the turnaround time
and the course of the test
you so much for the explanation um we do
i do want to remind the audience that
any questions that we don't have time
for and those submitted during the
uh during the on demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information
that you provided at the time of
registration so let's move on
to our next question this uh
looks like this question is going to be
a two-part question
so what are most important reasons for
loh
in prenatal and the second part is what
is suggested
what is the suggested minimal resolution
oh thank you so uh for prenatal just
like you know we
are falling on the acmg and and other
guidelines i think the most important
for the aoh or the upd region is uh
those related with
known imprinting gene so that is the
priority where we look at
but other regions is more like as i
mentioned is
if they are family runs in consecutivity
then we may want to pay attention
for those autosomal recessive conditions
they are already known
uh for the family
great thank you so much and it looks
like we do have time for
one more question in valentino we have
not forgotten about you this question is
actually going to be for you
is the fetal chip array commercially
available
and is it eight samples per slide or are
there options for
four or two for low throughput labs
thank you very much for the question the
array is an eight
sample per array and it will soon be
released
within our community design program so
it will be available
through the agilent website so please if
you have any interest
you can contact your local agent
representative we will be more than
happy to follow up
great thank you so much valentina and we
want to thank dr troy
for um for his presentation do you have
any final comments for our audience dr
choi
um um thank you for all and um you know
i have my email here so any of you if
you have uh
other questions you are most welcome to
email me or email valentine and we will
try our best to answer your questions
great thank you so much so thank you
again dr troy and thank you valentina
for joining us for that q and a session
we would like to also thank leopards and
our sponsor agilent
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and
until next time bye bye everyone
bye-bye